salut aujourd'hui je suis avec lauren
alias garita de la chaîne garita
lorraine sur sa chaîne elle fait du dit
heil c'est du do it yourself ont fait
nous-mêmes plein d'objets sa peine des
bijoux de la décoration des petits trucs
utiles tous les jours je ne suis pas un
bon bricoleur c'est comme ça donc
j'assume je ne peux pas avoir toutes les
qualités déjà que je chante extrêmement
bien aujourd'hui lorraine elle est venue
à la maison et on a fabriqué ensemble un
jeu ce jeu là c'est le jeu des bâtonnets
comme dans fort boyard je pense que
c'est un dérivé du jeu de nîmes
mais là c'est le jeu des bateaux des
versions le rennais fabien autant vous
le dire il dit level on va jouer à ça je
te propose qu'on fasse trois parties et
moi je vais écrire une petite prédiction
ici au caire
mon but ce n'est pas de gagner ou de
perdre mon but c'est surtout que la
prédiction se réalise voilà avec le mahb
et d'écriture je vous faire voir toi
faut pas que tu regardes parce qu'il ya
l'écran de retour comme vous vous lavez
des départs la prédiction tu as fait
cinq mois je peux être fier 7,4 aux
questions que c'est toi qui commence ah
oui la règle du jeu c'est quoi déjà
il faut que de prendre
on a le droit d'enlever un deux ou trois
et le but c'est de pas prendre le
dernier d'accord ok moi j'en enlève jeu
mais très sûrement ce passage-là en
accéléré je vous le dis je vais
accélérer ce passage
on
le but c'est de pas prendre les derniers
jeunes et bien je perd cette première
partie avec une dignement et avec
élégance et la prochaine fois
j'écouterai les consignes et donc tu
gagnes la première on joue toujours au
dès qu'ils commencent à ba2 5 - toujours
toi qui commence hier j'ai bien compris
j'ai envie d'en prendre trois tu vois
j'ai envie d'enfant j'ai envie qu'on
soit ex-aequo et je gagne cette nouvelle
partie dernières parties 5-4 et j'en
prends 3
les trois et je te laisse prendre le
dernier pour perdre dignement
tu as gagné la première mais tu as perdu
les deux autres est d'ailleurs j'avais
une petite prédiction avec moi la
prédiction je leur ai fait voir tout à
l'heure c'est le tableau des scores je
perds la première du gagne la 1ère et
ensuite je gagne les deux hôtes et toi
tu perds les deux autres donc là tu m'as
laissé gagner donc en fait à la fois
rejetée laisser gagner
je me suis toujours ça que tu fais c'est
peut-être là le but à l'heure en fait de
vote dans le trait à la la j'ai oublié
les règles je me souviens plus c'était
crédible
elle se redresse ainsi faire l'écart
merci pour ça j'ai utilisé une méthode
une méthode qui me permet de gagner à
tous les coups
à ce jeu quoi qu'il a que ce soit toi
qui commencent ou moi qui commence je
sais exactement comment faire depuis le
départ pour gagner et cette explication
je vais vous la donner c'est plutôt cool
mais je vais pas vous la donner ici je
vais vous la donner directement sur la
chaîne de lorraine je vais vous mettre
une fille juste ici qui renvoie vers la
chaîne de lorraine mais surtout vers la
vidéo où on vous explique tous les deux
parce que oui j'explique avec laurel
comment on a fabriqué ce jeu comment
vous pouvez vous le fabriquer et surtout
à la fin de la vidéo je vous donne
l'astuce pour pouvoir gagner à tous les
coups à ce jeu là et devenir le roi de
fort boyard et qui est vain bâton ou
l'infinité de bâton en fait une vraie
méthode
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé la vidéo
je vous donne rendez-vous dans quelques
secondes sur la chaîne de lorraine
profitez-en pour vous abonner à sa
chaîne parce que c'est vraiment cool si
ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas à nous le
faire savoir en laissant un petit
salaire pensez également à vous abonner
à la chaîne et rendez vous demain à 11
heures pour le prochain mentale blog
parce que c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an
ciao
oui